more than a week after the police
killing of George Floyd peaceful
protests continue across the country
amid unrelenting public outrage in Los
Angeles hundreds gathered outside the
mayor's house yesterday objecting to
police shooting tear gas and rubber
bullets at protesters tens of thousands
of people marched in Houston where City
Hall was lit up in the colors of George
Floyd's old high school Tony yeah New
York City's protest lasted all afternoon
and it continued after a nighttime
curfew set up because of outbreaks of
looting in previous nights we saw very
little of that though last night all
around the US and our national
correspondent Rica Duncan is in Foley
Square that's in lower Manhattan it's
the Justice Complex where one of many
demonstrations in New York took place
last night
Jericka good morning good morning to you
it's very calm and quiet here now but as
you can see there are barricades
surrounding me which were used to keep
protesters away from federal buildings
and area businesses and I've been out
here for the last couple days speaking
with those protesters all of them say
that they are here to stop police
violence and to demand equality there
were peaceful protests all over New York
City including Union Square doctors and
nurses from the front line for Kovan
also joined some of the demonstrations
we see how racism affects our patients
and their health and their lives just
like others do
even visitors to New York say they are
moved by the passion of the protesters
Samuel Cuomo's from Switzerland joined
them this issue protestors also spoke
out in cities from Indianapolis to Los
Angeles in Denver the police chief
marched arm and arm with the crowd they
have many of the same concerns we need
to bridge that gap we need to bridge
that divide protests have taken place in
at least 169 cities across all 50 states
more than 9,000 have been arrested
nationwide some for blocking highways
and breaking curfew but other arrests
include people who've taken advantage of
the situation by looting and stealing
crimes like those have distracted from
the protests in st. Louis the community
is mourning the loss of retired police
captain David Dorn who was shot and
killed early Tuesday during a looting at
a pawn shop and in one instance in
Atlanta six police officers were charged
and an assault of two college students
attempting to leave a protest last
weekend two of the officers involved
have already been fired from the
department the couple says they had
witnessed another friend being assaulted
by police before they were tased while a
news crew showed the incident live on
television what was that conversation
like from the time that you all were
thrown out of your cars kind of a
predetermined mindset year like they
basically are going out cleaning to
wreak havoc for no reason I asked
several times what do we do what's going
on
I don't understand and I was never once
told last night was certainly more calm
here in New York City when compared to
previous nights that a p.m. curfew
Anthony will remain in effect throughout
the week nari Jericka thank